Welcome back to the news you missed in 2020,
from every country in the world. If you haven’t
yet seen part one, make sure you go and watch
that first, unless, of course, you only care
about the small countries, because we’ll
start with one with a rather petite population
of just eight and a half million.
An 8-year-old boy who tried to use “spirit
money”—fake bills used in China as spiritual
offerings—at a grocery store in Switzerland
didn’t get Monopoly’s “Go to Jail”
card, but he did get a mugshot and now has
a police record. The heavy-handed punishment
for using counterfeit money surprised residents
because of the boy’s age and presumed naivety,
and caused some embarrassment for the country,
which discussed the case openly in parliament.
Chevron’s $4 billion acquisition of Texas-based
Noble Energy was an American transaction,
but was rooted in Israel. That’s because
Noble Energy has built a large natural gas
business in and around Israeli waters, and
the purchase essentially opens up the country
to energy development—a nation that had
remained virtually untouched to such activities
in order to maintain political stability with
Arab oil-producing countries. Not only does
the deal unlock the potential for a brand
new resource economy, but it demonstrates
that the Persian Gulf may now be more accepting
of Israeli business.
Togo became the first country in Africa to
eliminate “sleeping sickness,” a sometimes
fatal parasitic infection transmitted by flies,
found primarily in rural areas in 36 African
countries. Thanks to more than two decades
of dedicated public health measures, the West
African country eliminated the illness, which
causes fever, aches, and, most commonly, disrupts
a person’s sleep. The good news is that
cases are also dropping throughout Africa,
and the number of people dying has dropped
90% since the early ‘90 when the annual
death-toll reached a peak of 34,000.
Some more good news out of Africa is that
girls and young women who are pregnant in
Sierra Leone are no longer banned from attending
school. Previously, once pregnant, young women
were not allowed to finish school or take
their exams, but this decision is a victory
for feminism in the country, and will allow
tens of thousands of young women to potentially
complete their education and provide them
with more opportunity in life.
The crater of a meteorite that hit earth 800,000
years ago, blasting glass particles known
as tektites to over 10% of the planet, had
gone unfound... until now. Researchers think
they have located the impact crater—stretching
11 miles or 17 kilometers long by 8 miles
or 13 kilometers wide and filled with about
300 feet or 90 meters of rock—on a plateau
in Laos. Though a crater like this should
have presented itself through erosion over
eons, this elusive hole was covered by more
than 1,000 feet or 300 meters of lava flow,
and was only discovered on a hillside after
it was carved out to pave a road.
Brazilian World Cup football star Ronaldinho
spent the past six months in Paraguayan jail
and house arrest for entering the country
in March on an illegal passport. The star
player spent more than a month behind bars,
and was then transported to a luxury hotel
and held there for another four months, while
his legal troubles were sorted out between
the governments—he says he didn’t know
the passport was fake. During the latter part,
he reportedly had parties and sang karaoke,
leading people to wonder if prison is really
that bad.
Speaking of fake passports and punishment,
Raya, a three-month-old chihuahua, was facing
euthanasia for traveling from her home country
of Bulgaria to Norway, where she’d been
adopted, on a falsified passport until action
star Jean-Claude Van Damme stepped in, and
you can’t make this stuff up. Bulgaria initially
refused to take the dog back, until Van Damme
took to social media, and the country capitulated,
eventually repatriating her and putting her
up for adoption again.
Remember that story about Israel, natural
gas, and the Mediterranean Sea? We’re back
to it, but this time, with Lebanon involved.
The two countries started mediation for the
first time in 30 years over part of the sea
because of their dual interest in energy development.
Both say a 330 square mile, 850 square kilometer
area of the sea is part of their exclusive
economic zone. The two have been essentially
at a standstill for decades, and even though
they had to communicate through mediators
from the United States, their meeting marked
an historic moment.
More mediation in the Middle East actually
took place at the United Nations in Geneva,
but it led to a ceasefire between the two
main warring factions in Africa’s Libya.
The two sides have been engaged in a bloody
battle for years, and this newest peace attempt
brings some hope to both the country, and
to nearby nations that have previously tried
to intervene, such as Russia and Turkey.
As Nicaragua continues to develop its natural
resources, reports show that it may be doing
it at the cost of indigenous people’s lives.
The government is actively promoting illegal
land grabs for timber and mining companies,
and there have been reports that more than
40 native people have been killed—though
the police refuse to investigate. It’s all
the more complicated by the fact that President
Daniel Ortega has family ties to one of the
most active timber companies working in the
protected area.
Up the coast, Guatemala offered El Salvador
the opportunity to build a port on its lands
and waters, giving Atlantic Ocean access to
El Salvador, whose coastline is only on the
Pacific. In its initial phases, the port will
likely be constructed through a private-public
partnership and infrastructure, such as hotels
and warehouses, would be built around the
port as well, bringing a significant El Salvadorian
presence to its neighboring country.
Alright, try to keep up with this one: In
Kyrgyzstan, Central Asia’s only democracy,
the president resigned, after a week in hiding,
following a tumultuous election. A few hours
before his announcement, President Jeenbekov
said he would not step down amid the disputed
election, but then he did, and it left some
wondering if his quick about-face was triggered
by threats of violence from a criminal-backed
group. The new leader is a former kidnapper
who was sprung from jail by anti-government
protestors at the same time as Jeenbekov’s
resignation, raising many eyebrows.
Nearby, the president of Turkmenistan is widely
known for his obsession with a breed of dog
called the Alabai. So it didn’t come as
a surprise that he erected a 19-foot, 6-meter
gold statue of the shepherd-like canine in
a traffic circle in the country’s capital.
Turkmenistan is also known to have one of
the world’s more repressive governments,
and doesn’t even allow human rights organizations
into the country. That creates a definite
disconnect in terms of humanizing animals,
but treating humans inhumanely.
Investors and entrepreneurs have keyed in
on a new use for Australia’s desolate and
unforgiving outback: turn it into a solar
farm large enough to power the country of
Singapore. Sun Cable has announced a $20 billion,
10-gigawatt, 30,000-acre solar farm that will
send about ⅔ of the energy it produces north
through undersea high-voltage cables. If all
goes right, the lights of Singapore could
be solar-powered by 2027.
In another part of the global movement to
cleaner energy, Denmark, the European Union’s
largest oil producer, announced it would end
all oil and gas exploration in the North Sea
as part of its commitment to phase out fossil
fuel extraction by 2050. Its existing 55 platforms,
spread across 20 oil and gas fields, will
continue operations, but the decision to stop
looking for more sends a powerful message
to the world about the future of energy and
this country’s goals to be a green leader.
Some of the world may be saying goodbye to
fossil fuels, but an animal that oddly turns
out to like gas-powered vehicles, or at least
their sounds, is a monkey. A zoo in Finland
gave their white-faced saki monkeys a choice
between the sounds of traffic, the jungle,
zen, or dance music, and the primates overwhelmingly
preferred honking cars and screeching tires
over the mimicry of their natural habitat.
When Slovakian president Zuzana Caputova learned
that Chinese telecom giant Huawei was the
sponsor for a defense conference at which
she was slated to speak, she quickly pressed
end call and canceled her talk. She cited
security risks, along with following her basic
principles, since Huawei has been accused
of foreign interference. Huawei eventually
backed out of the conference and Caputova
ended up taking the stage, but the message
was heard loud and clear.
The World Wildlife Foundation has been working
for more than a decade to set up a national
park and nature reserve in the Republic of
the Congo, however, this year, the European
Union pulled their funding upon reports that
the anti-poaching guards patrolling the proposed
park have been engaging in physical violence
against the indigenous people of the area,
and are restricting them from moving around
on their own land. The World Wildlife Foundation’s
application for EU funding specifically stated
that the indigenous people of the area were
for the project, but given that that either
no longer, or was never true, it’s unclear
whether this project will move forward.
Only three countries still allow commercial
whaling, and Norway is one of them. Typically
the Scandanavian country sends most of its
whale meat to Japan, where demand is high,
but Norwegians are opting to consume more
of the meat for the first time in years, which
is probably due to the growing movement against
traditionally processed meat in favor of locally
sourced products, like the minke whales they
hunt in their own waters.
Close your eyes if you don’t want to see
something bizarre: It’s the wrinkle-faced
bat, native to Costa Rica. But of course what
one sees as ugly, others find… sexy? New
research this year found that these elusive
jungle-dwellers mate in an interesting way:
The males congregate in big groups, perform
a routine, and fold some of the extra skin
around their face up like a neck gaiter to
seduce the females… and, it seems to work.
Three Palestinian peace activitsts who held
a Zoom call with Israelis that included more
than 200 participants and viewers were charged
with “weakening revolutionary spirit.”
Their goal was part of a bridge-building initiative
called Skype with Your Enemy, but according
to Palestinian officials, communication with
Israel is considered a “normalization”
activity and punishable. The three could face
years in prison and hard labor sentences.
The Arab world’s longest-serving ruler,
the Sultan of Oman, died this year at age
of 79. Since he had no children, his cousin
was chosen to replace him, ending years of
speculation on which of the more than 80 potential
successors would gain the spot. Upon his passing,
the Sultan was recognized for his steadfast,
diplomatic reign by other world leaders. This
is a seemingly peaceful story about a leadership
change, amid a flurry of headlines this year
that were quite the opposite.
It’s easier to get to Liberia from France,
as well as other Western destinations, now
that Air France resumed its flight from Paris
to Monrovia after a nine-year hiatus. The
direct flight debuted on an Airbus a350, which
landed at a newly refurbished Robert International
Airport in Liberia. Officials boasted about
the newly improved connections between the
United States, United Kingdom, India, and
China with the return of this flight, and,
naturally, the strengthened ties between Liberia
and France.
When visitors to the North Pole buried a time
capsule there in 2018, they thought it would
be 40 years until it was discovered, but,
because of climate change and the fast-melting
Arctic, the “artifacts” were found much
sooner; they washed up on the shores of Ireland
this year, some 2,300 miles or 3,700 kilometers
away. That’s obviously another bad sign
for the Arctic, which some scientists say
will be ice-free by the summer of 2035.
Last year, a volcano on New Zealand’s White
Island erupted and killed 22 people, including
children and seniors, who were there with
tour groups. Now, 13 parties have been charged
in their deaths, with lawsuits claiming negligence
for allowing people to visit the site of an
active volcano. A family owns the island,
and tours were run by a small group of operators,
but the island has been closed to visitors
ever since.
A Sudanese militia leader who had been on
the run for 13 years was arrested in a remote
corner of the Central African Republic, near
the border with Sudan, which is where he allegedly
carried out crimes against humanity, including
mass campaigns of muder, rape, and looting
in the early 2000s, which partially contributed
to a humanitarian crisis in which 300,000
people were killed and 2.7 million were driven
from their homes. His arrest and subsequent
trial at the Hague will potentially bring
justice to many who have suffered in Darfur.
For several months, Mauritania banned Senegal
from fishing in its waters because of illegal,
unreported, and unregulated fishing, which
they say cost their country up to $300 million
in lost revenue. Now, under the new agreement,
Senegal will pay Mauritania for the actual
fish it catches, which means no more punitive
fines for the country instead. It seems like
a win-win for the two West African countries
and demonstrates some progress towards countries
all happily sharing the same pond.
In 2016, the Panama Papers exposed how some
of the world’s most prominent politicians,
business leaders, and celebrities set up offshore
bank accounts to conceal their wealth and
avoid taxes in the Central American country.
So, of course, Netflix made a movie about
it. But now, the law firm behind the 11.5
million documents is not happy about their
portrayal as “ruthless, uncaring, and unethical
lawyers,” so they’re doing the most lawyer
thing possible and suing Netflix. Jürgen
Mossack and Ramón Fonseca are claiming defamation
and asked for Netflix to cease streaming “The
Laundromat,” though it’s already been
screened to crowds at European film festivals.
Readers, writers, and free speech advocates
are rejoicing now that officials in Kuwait
disbanded a committee that banned more than
5,000 books over seven years. The country’s
Ministry of Information will no longer have
the control to censor titles like Victor Hugo’s
“The Hunchback of Notre Dame” and “One
Hundred Years of Solitude” by Gabriel García
Márquez. But, besides banning book imports,
the committee also had a say over every title
that was published in the country. Now they
don’t, and that means the words should flow
more freely.
Here’s a tip: If you’re German, but wanted
in the United States for building software
that tricks automobile emissions inspectors,
then don’t cross from Germany, where you’re
protected, into Croatia, where you’re not.
Apparently, former Volkswagen executive Alex
Eiser didn’t get the memo that only his
native country doesn’t extradite its own
citizens. He was arrested when crossing the
border in June, and will likely be charged
in the United States since America and Croatia
signed an extradition treaty last year. He’s
at the center of the emissions scandal in
which the German auto manufacturer tried to
evade US Clean Air laws by tricking the system,
and his arrest shows that the United States
isn’t finished with this car chase yet.
Moldova is veering away from its Putin-leaning
ways, at least temporarily, with its election
of Maia Sandu, a pro-Western, Harvard-educated
former prime minister, and its ouster of incumbent,
pro-Russian president Igor Dodon. Besides
favoring European ties, Sandu is also the
country’s first woman president. She ran
on an anti-corruption platform and championed
embracing the country’s Romanian roots—as
75% of the country speaks Romanian—over
its ties to Russia. Tiny Moldova is sandwiched
between Ukraine and Romania, which have also
leaned more Western in recent years, and the
results demonstrate this region’s increased
shift away from Russia.
If you’re tired of hearing about Georgia,
the US state, you can opt to move to the Eastern
European country of the same name to escape
the 24/7 news. The nation recently announced
a visa-free entry program, called Remotely
From Georgia, that grants year-long stays
to nationals of 95 countries. There are some
caveats: transplants must earn at least $2,000
per month and have health insurance, meaning
the country is looking for a certain type
of more permanent visitor—one that has money
and can contribute to its faltering economy.
The European Union is being held accountable
for the way it funds projects in Africa, thanks
to a group of Eritreans in the Netherlands.
They allege that the EU is paying for forced
labor by funding heavy construction equipment
to open and pave a road that connects the
Ethiopia-Eritrea border with the Eritrean
port of Massawa. That equipment is apparently
being run by conscripts. The project is part
of a $6 billion injection from the EU into
Africa as a way to curb migration from south
to north, but this case shows that more oversight
is needed in the process.
Another immigration story centers around a
steady stream of Argentinians relocating to
Uruguay, a move that the latter is quite happy
about. Uruguay enticed residents from its
southern neighbor by lowering the minimum
value of property required for tax residency
from $1.7 million to $380,000, and by offering
a 10-year “tax holiday.” That, in turn,
has led close to 20,000 people to flock north
this year, a number equivalent to about 0.6%
of Uruguay’s population of 3.5 million,
meaning the great pandemic migration continues.
Perhaps signaling that Bosnia-Herzegovina
is next on the luxury destination list, Saudi
developer Dar Al Arkan announced this year
it would build a 5-million-square-foot residential
and hotel complex outside of Sarajevo, making
it the largest real estate project in the
country’s history. This addition is being
touted as a second-home community that will
attract both Bosnian and international visitors,
and expand the developer’s global footprint.
When much of the world was brought to a standstill,
a Mongolian cuckoo made its most epic journey
yet: an 8,000 mile or 13,000 kilometer return
trip from South Africa to Mongolia, completing
a roundtrip journey that’s one of the longest
ever recorded for a land bird. Scientists
tracked the bird using a GPS tag to study
its habits, and were frankly surprised it
survived the year away, and 27 border crossings.
Though long-distance birds aren’t revelatory,
the lengths to which this species went are
notable, and perhaps poses more questions
than answers, such as, why go so far?
The Armenia-Azerbaijan war populated headlines
this fall, but notably absent from those stories
were the United States’ involvement in the
conflict. Prior to the Trump administration,
the United States actively engaged in previous
peace negotiations in the region, but the
America First doctrine that dominates the
current administration led to diplomatic disengagement
there. That said, the two countries still
agreed to a ceasefire, which has already been
tested and broken, according to Russian peacekeepers,
and now we’ll see if the Biden administration
plans to become more involved.
Move over rum, Jamaica is looking to a new
economic driver: bamboo. The government announced
efforts to boost bamboo production on the
island nation, which it sees as a more sustainable
revenue source. Bamboo is a quick-growing
plant that can be used as an alternative to
traditional wood products in tissues, paper,
and cloth. Caribbean island nations are, in
some cases, pushing for greener futures out
of necessity—in 2019 Jamaica banned plastic
bags and styrofoam—and also opportunity.
The EU’s getting a lot of attention, and
this time it’s because North Macedonia and
Albania have restarted negotiations to join
the 27-member institution. The two Balkan
countries were put on hold for two years after
some EU members questioned their track records
regarding democracy and corruption, but those
concerns have been assuaged and there’s
renewed momentum for the two to join neighbors
Serbia, Kosovo, Montenegro, and Bosnia in
entering the EU. Even with Great Britain’s
exit, the EU motto these days seems to be:
the more the merrier.
Qatar is Australia’s third biggest destination
for lamb exports, behind the US and China,
but that’s likely to change with the Arab
country canceling its subsidy of meat from
Down Under. The subsidies, which support this
$300-million-a-year trade, were set to expire
in 2023, but Qatar abruptly announced their
end this year. Some are linking the decision
to Australia’s criticism of Qatar’s treatment
of 13 Australian women earlier this year,
who were questionably strip-searched at Doha
International Airport. Qatar says that’s
not it, and rather it’s to bolster their
sustainability and independence.
If you’re one of those people who are sketched
out by large bodies of water and their unknown
contents, this won’t provide comfort. In
Lithuania, a team of divers completing a survey
for bridge repairs came across the remains
of a 16th century soldier, including leather
boots with spurs, a leather belt with a buckle,
and an iron sword. Though the current bridge
was built in 1934, records indicate there
was also one in its place 500 years ago. It’s
the first underwater remains to be found in
Lithuania, and researchers were impressed
by how well-preserved the skeleton was.
Know anyone looking for a pet elephant? Well,
Namibia has 170 of them for sale. That’s
because, despite the mammal being on the endangered
species list, they’re seeing a population
rebound in the south African country thanks
to successful conservation measures, jumping
from 7,500 in 1995 to 24,000 in 2019. But,
with their growth comes an increase in human-elephant
conflict as well as a fight for natural resources
during a drought year. Auctioning off some
of the pachyderms may alleviate some of the
stress and raise funds for the country.
President Adama Barrow assumed leadership
in The Gambia in 2017, following 22 years
of a brutal dictatorship, and at the time
he promised to call for new elections after
three years, instead of serving the full five-year
term. Well, guess what? Now he wants the full
five. Earlier this year, protestors took to
the streets to show their disappointment,
and in turn, 137 of them were arrested and
dozens more were detained. For some residents,
the show of force seemed like a harkening
back to the country’s darker days, and it
looks like Barrow will be staying in power.
The second-largest diamond ever mined was
unearthed in 2019, but it caused headlines
this year for its subsequent sale. It wasn’t
a diamond house or British royal that bought
the 1,758-carat gem, but French company Louis
Vuitton that purchased it from the Karowe
mine in Botswana. The sale isn’t only notable
because of its price—no numbers have been
released but some estimate around $50 million—but
because the buyer is a relative newcomer to
the super high-end jewelry market and this
boss move signals they’re here to stay.
Scientists in Gabon discovered their own treasure
this year, finding the largest pangolin ever
on record and tagging it for research purposes.
The scaly mammal is thought to be one of the
most frequently illegally trafficked animals
in the world—with much of the demand coming
from Asia—and researchers are hoping that
by learning about the creature’s habits
and movements, they’ll be better able to
protect it as demand increases for both its
meat and bones, which are often used in Chinese
medicine.
Former Lesotho prime minister Thomas Thabane
has denied any role in his ex-wife’s murder,
despite police reports that say that he previously
paid a $20,000 down payment for her killing,
which was part of a $180,000 total sum. His
ex-wife was shot in a car, two days before
his inauguration. Before that, she rejected
getting a divorce so that she could remain
the First Lady. He remarried two months after
her death, but was forced to resign from power
amid the controversy.
North Macedonia, which only became “North”
in 2019 to differ itself from the Greek region
of Macedonia, has the potential to delineate
itself through marijuana production too—if
the government will support it. Though medical
marijuana has been legal in the country since
2016, there’s a new push to legalize cannabis
in all forms, and to ramp up production to
supply Western European countries with pot,
where sale and consumption are permitted in
modest quantities—but huge grow operations
are not. Toward the end of 2020, government
officials signaled their support to make North
Macedonia a “cannabis superpower.”
Burning and removing statues has been a thing
this year, and a wood depiction of Melania
Trump erected in her hometown of Sevnica,
Slovenia was no exception. Someone set fire
to the statue in July, so the artist took
the reasonable action of replacing it in more
permanent bronze. That was probably a good
idea, since the small town of 5,000 residents
has seen upwards of 20,000 Melania-tourists
a year since 2016, when President Trump took
office.
Vultures may not be the cutest birds, but
they’re one the animal kingdom needs for
their scavenger role. Unfortunately, the hooded
vulture in Guinea-Bissau inched closer to
extinction this year, with the accidental
poisoning of more than 1,000 of the birds.
There, residents put strychnine in the landfills
to ward off feral dogs, with the unintended
consequence of it being consumed by the scavenging
birds. This actually happens a lot in Africa,
and the vulture population across the continent
is highly threatened because of it.
A woman in Latvia made headlines for taking
10 days off after her child was born—because
she took it as paternity leave. Previously,
same-sex couples in the country had not been
granted the right to both take parental leave,
but she fought the ruling as unconstitutional
and was the first woman in the country to
use her paternity leave.
Arab countries trying to get the attention
of Europeans are doing it in perhaps the most
obvious way ever, through soccer—or football
for the rest of the world. That’s why Bahrain
purchased a minority stake in football club
Paris F.C. this year, with a direct goal to
attract more Europeans to the Gulf State,
which is still feeling the negative effects
of stifling pro-democracy uprisings during
the Arab Spring and is therefore trying to
patch up its global reputation.
We hear a lot about the migration crises of
people traveling from Africa to Europe and
Central America to the United States, but
a movement that gets less coverage is the
one of Venezeulans --many of which go to Trinidad
and Tobago. By late 2020, there were almost
20,000 registered refugees in the island nation,
but amid the ones who make it, there are tragic
stories too. Most recently, 11 Venezuelans,
including children, died in a boat trying
to cross the Gulf of Paria, which separates
Trinidad from the Venezuelan coast by just
under 7 miles or 11 kilometers.
When a constitutional referendum passed in
Guinea earlier this year that allowed the
president to run for a third term instead
of ending at two, it was certainly created
with President Alpha Conde in mind. There
were protests then, and again when he was
re-elected in October with nearly 60% of the
vote. Since the results, dozens have died
in the demonstrations but that didn’t stop
him from being sworn into office earlier this
month.
Cyber-warfare seems like something that happens
in the ether, but American operatives actually
traveled to Estonia prior to the American
election in November to learn about the northeastern
European country’s sophisticated defense
tactics. Specifically, the US had Russian
hackers in mind, and Estonia has one of the
stronger defense networks because Russia used
to test its malware and disinformation campaigns
there.
A whistleblower from a 2004 case between Australia
and East Timor continues to draw attention,
and this year the lawyer for the anonymous
whistleblower, referred to as Witness K, won
a free speech prize for his work on the case.
Witness K and lawyer Bernard Colleary revealed
that Australia was spying on conversations
between East-Timorese officials about oil
and gas negotiations in the Timor Sea. East
Timor is one of the poorer countries in the
world, and the whistleblowing did help the
country get a fairer financial deal.
Mauritius is an Indian Ocean island country
that sees 1.3 million visitors each year,
many coming for its lagoons, tropical jungles,
and mountains, but a Japanese oil tanker ran
ashore in July spilling 1,000 tons of fuel
into the sea, and since then more than 40
dolphins have washed up on shore. Some are
worried the disaster could extend beyond dying
dolphins and severely impact the country’s
environment and therefore its primary tourist
draw--the pristine nature.
Those who are in, are in, but now that Cyprus
has shut the door on its golden passport program,
it will be harder for people to buy their
way into the European Union. More than 3,000
foreigners who agreed to invest $2 million
each into the country benefited from the program
in its seven-year existence, but new allegations
of--and no one could have guessed this--corruption
have led officials to suspend the program.
But that’s not to say it wasn’t worth
it--Cyprus raised $7 billion from it, all
told.
Eswatini joined an exclusive club this past
fall--countries that have consulates to Morocco
in the Western Sahara. As covered earlier,
this is a disputed zone claimed both by Morocco
and the Polisario Front, and many countries
choose not to state a strong position on the
issue. With the opening of a consulate to
Morocco in the Western Saharan city of Laayoune,
however, the Kingdom of Eswatini is firmly
positioning itself on Morocco’s side, and
it becomes the 15th country to open a consulate
to Morocco in the area.
Do you remember the chameleon that hadn’t
been seen for 100 years in Madagascar? There’s
another good story like it out of Djibouti,
where a mouse-sized elephant shrew has been
seen again for the first time in 50 years.
The good news in this case, unlike with the
chameleon, is that the shrew’s habitat isn’t
under threat so scientists finding 12 animals
from the 1,000 traps set hopefully means it
won’t be another 50 years until they’re
seen again.
When it comes to sharing good news, Fiji beat
out all other countries to become the first
nation to congratulate President-elect Joe
Biden on his victory. Fijian Prime Minister
Frank Bainimarama sent out the celebratory
tweet before any other heads of state, but
it wasn’t purely altruistic. In the tweet,
he called for action on the planet’s climate
emergency, and asked Biden to bring the United
States back into the Paris Agreement.
Think back to the origins of the pandemic,
when the world still thought it would be confined
to China. That’s when the tiny island-nation
of the Comoros got some media attention for
giving China 100 Euros as a show of solidarity
in fighting the virus. Of course, few places
would be untouched, and it did hit the Comoros
in late April, but ultimately the Chinese-Comoros
relationship is ongoing, as the world’s
most populated country continues to invest
in the East African island as part of its
military and economic strategy.
Guyana is poised to be one of the world’s
next big oil producers, but there are some
who aren’t happy about that potential. ExxonMobil
found sites that could potentially deliver
8 billion barrels of oil, which could amount
to more than $20 billion in revenue for one
of South America’s poorer countries. The
World Bank has pledged $55 million to help
the country in its development, but critics
say this opposes global goals of curbing fossil
fuel dependency.
China, India, and Bhutan are in ongoing negotiations
over their definitive borders—the 25th round
of talks was delayed this year because of,
well, you know, everything—but that didn’t
stop impatient Chinese from constructing and
inhabiting a village 1 mile or 1.6 kilometers
within Bhutan’s recognized border this year.
This territorial grab is something China continues
to do, especially to its immediate neighbors
such as Bhutan, which has just under 800,000
residents and poses little threat to the world
and military superpower.
What do China, Iran, North Korea, and the
Solomon Islands all have in common? Well,
as of now, it’s a Facebook ban. The South
Pacific nation plans to join the three countries
in banning the social media site because,
according to officials, citizens are using
it to abuse political leaders and access dangerous
information. Facebook was used as an organizing
tool for protests that crippled the nation’s
capital last year, and critics of the ban
say this is a move to stop criticism of the
government.
The United States military is the strongest
in the world, and other countries want a piece
of it. For $36 million, Montenegro was able
to buy a taste: 67 Joint Light Tactical Vehicles.
The agreement is part of a NATO ally deal
that allows such transactions between countries,
and Montenegro is on the United States’
friendly list as Western allies try to massage
the region out of its Russian-dominated past.
Looking to ease traffic congestion, Luxembourg
became the first country in the world to offer
public transportation entirely for free. Officials
say it could save households roughly $125
per year, and also encourage public transportation
use versus private vehicles, which account
for 71% of leisure travel and 47% of business.
A new tramway in the country’s capital is
one attractive alternative for riders. There
is an exception, though: first-class passengers
will still have to pay.
South America’s Suriname is switching gears,
with the election of a new president who replaces
a dictator-turned-populist running on a poor
economic record and penchant for corruption.
The new president, Chan Santokhi, assumes
leadership of a country on the brink of financial
collapse and diplomatic disarray—in recent
years, the country turned to China and Venezuela
for global ties, but Santokhi will be tasked
in realigning the country with its former
imperial power, the Netherlands.
When a Japanese couple on a world tour/honeymoon
were stranded due to pandemic travel bans
on the 10 tiny islands off the coast of West
Africa known as Cape Verde, they settled in
for five months and got to know the locals.
Now, they’ll be ambassadors for the nation
at the upcoming summer Olympics in Tokyo.
Cape Verde is sending three to four athletes,
and though they’ve never won a medal in
the summer games, they will at least be well
represented this time.
Global superpowers continue to fight for strategic
power on islands throughout the world, and
this time, the United States has its eyes
on the Maldives, where it announced it is
opening an embassy. The string of 1,100 islands
is also in the crosshairs of India and China,
which have financially supported the nation.
Particularly, China has lent the country millions
in infrastructure loans, which the Maldives
are finding increasingly hard to pay back
and that potentially puts them in a debt-trap
diplomacy situation. The US has promised a
different approach.
Our favorite nature narrator Sir David Attenborough
gifted 7-year-old Prince George a prehistoric
shark tooth that he collected while on family
vacation in Malta more than 50 years ago.
Malta did not appreciate the gesture. Officials
said the 23-million-year-old fossil, which
likely belonged to a megalodon, should rightfully
find its place among their own country’s
cultural heritage. The Maltese eventually
formally decided to let it slide this time,
opting to avoid making the young prince cry.
A couple cases of beer may sound like a party
in some countries, but in Brunei, for a foreigner,
it meant getting questioned by police. An
Indonesian national was found with 57 beers
in his car at a road stop, which was a problem
for him, because alcohol is actually illegal
in the country. There is an exception for
non-Muslim foreigners who are allowed to possess
up to 12 cans or 2 liters of beer, but he
had four times the limit… and that’s a
party foul.
It appears that fish off the coast of Belize
have tamed a shrimp species in the same-ish
way that humans domesticated dogs—at least
according to new scientific research. Apparently,
the damselfish aggressively defends a patch
of algae against all predators because that’s
where it harvests food, but it allows mysid
shrimp to hang around. In turn, the shrimp
fertilize the algae so it’s better food
for the damselfish. After time, the shrimp
rely on the fish for protection, and that’s
domestication.
Exploratory drilling near the Bahamas and
150 miles or 240 kilometers from the Florida
coast is set to take place soon, despite opposition
from environmental groups and a ban from the
United States on offshore drilling. That’s
because the Bahamas Petroleum Company has
leases on potential oil fields in the area,
and they’re exercising them. Some are worried
about the environmental effects should something
go wrong, as has been the case time and time
again, but the Bahamas sees dollar signs that
it needs in order to compensate for the financial
hit it took when tourism ground to a halt
this year.
Researchers studying islanders in a less tropical
part of the world found one interesting, and
potentially evolutionary, trait. It seems
that 2% of Iceland’s residents can’t smell
foul fish. In fact, when presented with the
malodorous sample, they pleasantly detected
caramel, rose, or potatoes. These scientific
human specimens possess a mutation that turns
off their TAAR5 gene—you know, the one responsible
for making a protein that recognizes trimethylamine,
aka a chemical found in rotten fish, and sometimes
human sweat and urine.
Vanuatu is a country that’s been hit hard
by Mother Nature, having experienced two volcanic
eruptions and two category-five cyclones in
the past five years. Disaster relief is something
officials there are having to learn quickly
and execute often. To do so, one system they’ve
recently implemented is distributing emergency
relief funds to residents via blockchain technology
and tap-and-pay cards. The cards are loaded
with “money” that residents can use immediately,
and it avoids some of the red tape that typically
consumes relief efforts.
Racial reckoning sparked movements worldwide,
and that groundswell did not leave the island
of Barbados untouched. This most Eastern island
in the Caribbean formally announced it would
remove Queen Elizabeth as its head of state
and become a republic in 2021, citing long-simmering
tensions about the legacy of colonization
and racial injustice. Some see the island’s
decision to part with the monarchy as a tipping
point for neighboring countries who may also
seek their own independence.
To help young women in Sao Tome and Principe,
the World Bank announced its commitment of
$15 million to empower young girls. Providing
safe learning spaces in schools is one of
the immediate goals of the funding, where
dropping out and pregnancy are common for
girls at a young age. Concurrently, but unrelated
to the funding, the country’s national Olympic
committee announced a push to encourage girls
ages 6 to 18 into surfing lessons—another
way to steer young women into positive alternatives,
and potentially build their summer Olympics
team.
Samoa’s state-owned flag carrier Samoa Airways
was reporting financial trouble at a loss
of $25 million in 2019, according to reports.
That was before this year, and the decimation
of passenger demand—and so it’s not looking
any better for them. The airline also reportedly
owes $11 million to creditors, but, of course,
executives are painting a rosier picture.
This all comes as Samoa Airways tries to complete
its lease negotiations for a Boeing 737-800
from the Netherlands, and further debt could
hinder those.
When it comes to the world’s top honeymoon
destination, there’s one place that keeps
blowing every other location out of international
waters, so to speak: St. Lucia. The Caribbean
island was named the number one honeymoon
locale for the twelfth time, and third consecutive
year. The World Travel Awards were announced
virtually in Moscow this year, and hopefully,
by this time next year, people won’t have
to take a virtual honeymoon to St. Lucia.
Climate change is impacting all islands, including
the 32 atolls that comprise the nation of
Kiribati. That’s why President Tanati Maamau
will accept funding from China to dredge sand
along the most populous islands to actually
raise them out of the sea. Some see this as
a strategic play by China to inch further
into the Pacific Ocean, where military presence
closer to the United States would definitely
be a power move. Maamau, however, says Kiribati
would not grant China the gift of building
a base on its nearby Christmas Island, which
just happens to be relatively close to Hawaii.
The Federated States of Micronesia are composed
of more than 600 islands stretching 1,600
miles or 2,700 kilometers across the Pacific
Ocean. The country’s population is quite
small in comparison to the vastness that gives
it the 14th largest exclusive economic zone
in the world. This is what makes the rescue
of three stranded men who wrote “SOS”
in the sand on a deserted atoll most impressive.
They’d run out of fuel and drifted 118 miles
or 190 kilometers west of their departure
point, and were spotted by a search plane
three days after their departure.
Another stranded-island story transports us
to Grenada, where a British woman visiting
the Caribbean island found herself stuck thanks
to the spring’s travel bans. The problem
is that she was six months pregnant, and ended
up delivering her child on the island, prematurely.
She ended up securing a repatriation flight
in June; becoming one of tens of thousands
of British who were chartered back from at
least 57 countries.
We’re getting to the smaller countries and
most of them are islands. During 2015, a 30-mile,
50-kilometer algal bloom made a slow water-surface
crawl into the Pacific and scientists were
baffled by what caused it, until a report
was released this year. The patch was created
by Tonga island runoff, rich in iron and phosphorus.
This is common, but its delayed appearance
is not, and that’s what confused scientists.
It took some time for a nitrogen fixer to
utilize the nutrients, making it seem like
the bloom came out of nowhere when it had
actually slow-cooked it’s way across the
ocean.
Travel between Ukraine and St Vincent and
the Grenadines became easier following the
signing of a visa-free travel agreement between
the two countries. The Caribbean country is
part of the Commonwealth of Nations, a political
association of 54 members, nearly all former
territories of the British Empire. Ukraine
has its eyes on some of the more powerful
Commonwealth members granting visa-free travel,
or at least the ambassador tweeted an allusion
to that, with Australia, the UK, and Canada
on his wish list.
It’s been 44 years since the Seychelles
secured its independence from Britain, and
this year marked the first time that a president
from the opposition party won an election
since the country’s British breakaway. That’s
being heralded as a step toward greater democracy,
with Wavel Ramkalawan defeating an incumbent
from the United Seychelles party, which had
been in power since 1977.
British sailor and 72-year-old man Graham
Walters was super-social distancing when he
sailed from Great Britain to Antigua, setting
the record for the oldest person to cross
the Atlantic Ocean solo. It was actually his
fifth trip across the ocean, and he narrowly
went awry at the end when strong winds blew
him six miles or 10 kilometers off course
of Antigua. He was able to call the coast
guard and get a tow to his final destination
and officials still counted it as a world
record even with the assist.
One of the tiniest European countries, Andorra,
joined the big-guns and became the 190th nation
to become a part of the International Money
Fund. But why now? Well, crisis financing,
mostly, which the IMF comes through on for
countries in need, among other missions. Trade
and tourism—mostly ski resorts and hiking
trails—contribute to 40% of the mountainous
country’s economy, and they’re hurting
right now with lack thereof.
A Caribbean island that’s counting on tourism
and the economy bouncing back is Dominica.
It announced its intentions to build a new
long-haul airport, capitalizing on a growing
eco-tourism and offshore financial sector.
Currently visitors must transfer to Dominica
through a neighboring island, but this new
airport would make direct trips from the United
States, United Kingdom, and Western Europe
more possible. Officials say it will be largely
financed by foreigners who pay in exchange
for a passport, but it seems that we’ve
heard that story before.
What drifts away from the coast of Mexico
likely ends up at the Marshall Islands, according
to computer simulations. In this case, it
was a boat full of cocaine. Without any evidence
or leads, law enforcement officials have theorized
that a ghost boat filled with 1,430 pounds
or 650 kilograms of the illegal drug came
from the Mexican or Central American coast,
and it had probably been floating captain-less
for at least a year. Though drugs have washed
up on shore before, this was the largest ever
haul and it was quickly incinerated.
It seems that Caribbean islands are all vying
for new citizens and the influx of money they
bring. St. Kitts and Nevis has made the process
so easy that wealthy investors can get citizenship
in under 60 days—one of the fastest tracks
in the world—without even having to step
foot in the country, and for that they’ve
been recognized by The Financial Times for
having one of the best citizen-by-investment
programs. For $150,000, a family of four can
call Saint Kitts their second, or third, or
fourth, home.
Sir Jim Ratcliffe is another wealthy individual
moving to sunnier skies; he’s leaving the
United Kingdom for Monaco, where he’ll save
up to $5.4 billion in taxes. Ratcliffe is
a petrochemicals magnate with an estimated
worth of $23.6 billion. People who live in
Monaco for at least 183 days a year don’t
pay income or property taxes, and that’s
a lot different from the up to 45% he could
be paying under the UK’s tax system.
Sandwiched between Austria and Switzerland,
Liechtenstein said no to developing an international
rail system. The country is only 15 miles,
or 25 kilometers, long and has just one domestic
track. This initiative would have widened
it and upgraded one of its terminals so that
international trains could stop there, but
voters turned down the project at the polls--balking
at the $73.5 million price tag.
With a 6 pm curfew in Italy due to lockdowns,
residents looking for a little nightlife are
hopping the border into San Marino, where
bars and restaurants are open until 10 pm.
The small, independent country is just 10
minutes from cities such as Rimini, and Italian
officials are frustrated that by San Marino
not falling in line with their own guidelines,
they’re putting more citizens at risk of
spreading the virus.
Palau, about 1,000 miles or 1,600 kilometers
from the Philippines, has a free-association
agreement with the United States that delivers
significant financial aid, and gives Palauans
the right to travel to, live, and work in
the US. But that current compact expires in
2024, and Palau wants even more US presence—they’ve
invited America to build a military base on
their island. Currently Palau has no military,
and they see an American base there as a way
to bolster security, and for the United States,
it’s a way to push back against growing
Chinese influence in the region.
The Perth Mint in Australia produces Tuvalu’s
currency, including the Tuvalu dollar, which
is used alongside the Australian dollar, and
a series of collectible coins. This year,
Tuvalu issued a coin of American film star
John Wayne that has been selling for more
than $100. It turns out, the collectible coin
business is quite lucrative for the tiny island,
which receives about $200,000 a year in royalties.
The coins are technically legal tender, but
moreso they’re purchased by international
collectors.
Australia uses the tiny Micronesian island
of Nauru as an outpost for refugees to spend
time while their claims are processed. In
combination with Papua New Guinea, where detainees
are also kept, there are about 300 people
held, but Australia spent $1.2 billion this
financial year to keep them there, equally
about $4 million per person. This is causing
many to turn their heads at the exorbitant
costs that would be better spent just keeping
those refugees in Australia. On top of that,
conditions in the refugee camps are poor and
sometimes dangerous, so the money has not
been well spent.
And here we are, the world’s smallest country:
the Vatican City. This year, it has a very
2020 story: Catholicism’s headquarters may
have missed the mark on the Nativity scene.
Each year the holy city produces a new scene
donated by an Italian city. This year Castelli,
a town known for ceramics, got the spotlight,
but the curious stylings of coiled clay meet
astronauts have received curious reviews.
Castellians made the figures over decades,
and they’ve survived natural disasters and
more. One observer saw hope in the scene:
“It’s a Nativity scene that has had problems,
like we’ve all had a lousy year,” she
said. “If it made it, we can.”
And that’s it--that’s the news you missed
in 2020, or at least some of it, from every
country in the world. If you’ve made it
to this point, you’re clearly a lover of
learning about the world. Therefore, I’m
going to recommend you an audiobook from our
sponsor, Audible, that I’d honestly be stunned
if someone who made it through all 195 countries
has not already listened to. It’s Prisoners
of Geography, by Tim Marshall, which is this
fascinating read about how geography constrains
countries--it explains things like why Putin
is so focused on Crimea, why Europe will never
be united, and why the US was destined to
become a superpower. You can actually listen
to this completely for free by signing up
for a free trial to Audible Premium Plus at
Audible.com/Wendover. That subscription includes
the traditional credit system that allows
you to get any audiobook in their catalogue,
plus the new way to consume audio entertainment:
Audible Plus. This gives you unlimited access
to a massive catalogue of Audiobooks, Audible
Originals, podcasts, and more, which gives
you great content that can entertain and educate
you anytime your ears are free. If you’re
just interested in Audible Plus, which is
a fantastic deal by itself, Audible has an
even better deal just for the holidays. By
going to Audible.com/Wendover or texting “wendover”
to 500-500, you can get unlimited audio entertainment
with Audible Plus for $4.95 a month for six
months, and you’ll be supporting the channel
while you’re at it.